the scp foundation is an organization
that polices the abnormal in all its
forms whether it's a multi-dimensional
chaos god a big scaly monster or a very
effective coffee machine the foundation
takes appointed interest in pretty much
anything outside the norm so you're
probably wondering what would they want
with mr smith a man who was about as
normal and average as could be
mr smith was a 47 year old
african-american construction worker
with a wife and daughter he lived a
modest but contented life he had a close
circle of friends a happy family and was
well liked among his coworkers but mr
smith had no idea about the anomalous
nightmare barreling down the tracks
towards him mr smith wasn't just about
to have his life destroyed by an anomaly
he was about to become one it seemed
like a normal day at work on the
construction site when he received a
phone call it was the police informing
him that his wife and young daughter had
been involved in a terrible car accident
while this is anyone's worst nightmare
it was only the start of the horrifying
things that were about to happen to poor
poor mr smith that night when mr smith
went to sleep he fell victim to a
strange phenomenon he started to
disappear while it would be easy to
write off as the result of mental
illness like a kind of stressed induced
mental breakdown mr smith wasn't the
only one who noticed or rather
didn't notice his co-workers would
slowly begin to forget details about him
even obvious things that you could glean
from simply looking at a person like
clothes height or skin color it seemed
that little by little ever since his
family died mr smith was becoming an
unperson this led to increasing levels
of fear paranoia and distress as people
whom he'd thought of as his closest
friends could barely recognize him
anymore thankfully mr smith wasn't just
going to slip into non-existence without
a fight he realized early on that his
new condition seemed to abide by certain
rules the effects got worse in the night
when he was alone but seemed to lessen
somewhat during the day when he was
interacting with people it seemed that
he disappeared just that little bit more
whenever he wasn't being interacted with
and perhaps he hadn't developed this
condition upon the death of his wife and
child maybe he'd had it for a while but
it was the constant presence of his
family that kept the effects from
worsening but now that he'd properly
identified the problem mr smith could
begin devising some solutions if nobody
else was there to interact with him at
night he'd keep his position in reality
stable by interacting with himself mr
smith would repeat his own name to
himself regularly reaffirming his
existence to himself he'd often check
his own pulse to feel the rhythm of his
heartbeat he'd write detailed
descriptions of himself either on his
own body or a surrounding surface and in
one particular stroke of genius he
devised a method of recording his own
voice talking to himself and playing it
back while he was asleep to stave off
reality decay
during the day while at work or just
existing socially in the world he do
everything he could to constantly
interact with people that way they could
keep reaffirming his presence and
therefore continuing his existence the
symptoms of mr smith's condition are
somewhat similar to a rare mental
illness known as the kotar delusion in
which a patient believes they are dead
dying or don't even exist except in mr
smith's unfortunate case the delusion
was becoming a reality and this was a
reality that mr smith could only hold
off for so long little by little the
coping mechanisms he'd built to manage
his new life began to collapse people in
his inner circle truly began to forget
him his company no longer recognized him
as an employee to the people who barely
knew him he was little more than a ghost
a kind of palpable absence
this was the point when the scp
foundation finally got involved they
swooped in and apprehended mr smith
redesignating him as
scp-1467 it was one of the rare
occasions that the foundation didn't
need to apply any amnestic treatment to
bystanders because due to the nature of
mr smith's anomalous activity almost
everyone who knew him was already in the
process of forgetting him when the
foundation interviewed a man that mr
smith referred to as a close friend he
couldn't even recall mr smith's basic
physical traits with any reliability
because of mr smith's condition the
foundation had real difficulty verifying
elements of his backstory mr smith told
the foundation researchers everything
about himself about his family and his
life before but field agents were
stumped whenever they tried to follow up
on the information first there were
issues with the existence and fate of
his supposed wife and child no records
were ever found of either of these
people existing and there was no
existing documentation to prove that mr
smith was ever married the foundation
also looked into the deaths of mrs smith
and her child there were no records of a
car crash in the area that mr smith
directed them to but that's not all
there were also no death records nor any
graves ever found the construction
company that mr smith claimed to work
for had no records of his employment
they couldn't find any of mr smith's
supposed extended family either the only
proof that he had ever existed was his
physical body locked in a foundation
humanoid containment cell and mr smith's
own words if you think this sounds like
a living nightmare then mr smith would
wholeheartedly agree with you the
effects of his anomalous nature
traumatized mr smith he was diagnosed by
foundation therapists as suffering from
bipolar depression as well as chronic
sleep deprivation though if you
disappeared a little more every time you
slept you'd probably lose a lot of sleep
too the unpredictable nature of mr
smith's anomalous traits could have
equally unpredictable effects on the
nature of his containment so he was
classified as euclid mr smith is one of
the few anomalies that is referred to by
his real name at least to his face when
referred to as
scp-1467 mr smith enters a state of rage
and panic and this mistake has caused
several injuries for foundation
personnel during attempts to restrain
him after using his scp number around
him mr smith is contained in a
foam-padded cell to prevent
self-destructive behavior along with
three audio recording devices though
these were installed at his own request
in order to continue his habit of
recording his own voice to play back to
himself while asleep this served the
dual purpose of not only mitigating his
fading from reality but also keeping him
calm and docile during containment and
these devices are kept in good working
order in order to avoid creating
hostility between mr smith and
foundation's staff while it may seem
that the anomalous effects of mr smith
purely serve to create a personal hell
for him and him alone the foundation
wasn't so sure the fact no records could
be found of his wife daughter or
extended family was concerning it raised
one frightening question are the effects
of mr smith's condition contagious if so
he could be putting a lot of people in
grave danger foundation scientists
headed by senior researcher dr thorne
devised a series of experiments to
better understand mr smith's mysterious
condition there were 22 experiments in
total but things began to get
interesting at around experiment 16. for
this experiment mr smith was forcibly
restrained and brought into a research
chamber with research assistants rainier
and dieter they were told to simply
observe mr smith without interacting
with him and record what happened in the
process while dr thorne supervised at 10
minutes and 12 seconds the researchers
were unable to recognize the subject as
mr smith had 14 minutes and 32 seconds
they were unable to recognize the
clothes of mr smith less than 10 minutes
later they were unable to identify his
race five minutes after that they
couldn't identify what mr smith was
currently doing 10 minutes later they
couldn't even identify how mr smith was
sitting at almost 40 minutes the
research assistants weren't able to
identify anything of mr smith save for
the fact that there was some kind of
humanoid creature in the room at this
point research assistant dieter started
a recording instructing mr smith to
describe himself on record as this
happened smith returned to a describable
state curled up in a fetal position on
the floor there was no sign of the
restraints or the chair in which smith
had been placed subsequent tests showed
similar results with minor variations
and timing just by being in physical
contact with mr smith the chair and the
restraints had literally faded out of
existence evidence was really pointing
towards mr smith's anomalous effects
being potentially detrimental to the
people and objects around him but the
experiments continued they had to know
more before there was nothing left to
know the next series of experiments were
performed with d-classes and led dr
thorne and his team of researchers to a
number of frightening conclusions two
d-classes locked in with mr smith as he
slipped out of existence began
experiencing extreme states of terror
and distress even when they could no
longer see him they could still feel the
presence of an entity in the room when
the two d-classes tried to escape one of
them was almost mistaken for mr smith
himself he too was now starting to slip
out of existence both d-classes were
summarily terminated and dr thorne began
to wonder whether mr smith's condition
was contagious or if he was instead
somehow able to lash out at others in
his vicinity in a more localized fashion
only two other experiments were ever
performed on mr smith before further
experimentation into his case was
permanently suspended in the first a
non-violent d-class was placed in mr
smith's cell and ordered to ignore him
mr smith didn't take this well he began
attacking the d-class who fought back
breaking mr smith's nose ironically this
physical attack was actually beneficial
to mr smith as the violence helped
ground him in reality and secured his
existence just that little bit more in
the final experiment mr smith was given
a cellmate a female d-class who was
allowed to acknowledge him the two
appeared to become close and their time
helps stave off mr smith's fading just a
little bit longer it's unknown if she
contracted his fading condition or
somehow was able to escape but one day
while mr smith slept she simply
disappeared mr smith fell into a state
of almost catatonic silence soon after
he began to speak again only to repeat i
don't want to go again and again and
again
experiments concluded for good not long
after because of his delicate mental
state mr smith is allowed a visit from a
therapist every week and before any
future experiments are performed on mr
smith researchers are required to seek
permission from his active therapist
because of his effects on the minds of
people aware of him foundation protocol
is to terminate mr smith immediately if
he ever breaches containment the site
director has also appended a memo to
smith's file instructing personnel to
refer to mr smith as
scp-1467 whenever he's out of your shot
doing otherwise will incur severe
punishments records on mr smith are
backed up in six separate copies and
stored in different locations in hopes
that this will prevent the information
from decaying like mr smith's existence
mr smith's stories one of pain tragedy
and existential horror there's no
shortage of scps that can cause xk-class
end-of-the-world scenarios but sometimes
the terror of these anomalies pales in
comparison to scps that can bring one
person's world crashing down around them
according to all the scp foundation's
studies it's likely that mr smith will
disappear sometime soon
regardless of their intervention now
check out
scp-096 look at a picture of the shy guy
in space shy guy questions and theories
and scp-5031
yet another murder monster for more scp
foundation mysteries explored